centre de distribution amazon ont été
partiellement fermés à brampton à la
suite d'éclosion de kobe 19 et une
dizaine d'autres lieux de travail sont
sous enquête dans la ville reine depuis
vendredi
toute entreprise ayant cinq employés
infectés ou plus dans les régions de
piles et de toronto devront fermer pour
dix jours des éclosions attendait de
comparaître à pile le taux de positivité
au virus est supérieure à 20% et la
plupart des personnes infectées leçon
sur leur lieu de travail pour a dit qu'à
ces nouvelles mesures arrivent trop tard
son père est mort en février après avoir
contracté la co vidal usine pour
laquelle il travaillait depuis 26 ans
les fermetures en cas d'éclosion devrait
devenir obligatoire partout dans la
province
selon elle cela nécessite toutefois un
soutien financier pour ses employés qui
devront s'isoler chez eux en attendant
le programme de congés de maladie payés
promis par le gouvernement fold dans ce
décret est fort pour des employeurs à de
données qui étaient touchés attaque avec
ses degrés il faut aussi vacciner ces
travailleurs essentiel rapidement selon
les experts les bénéfices vont bon être
présent pas seulement pour les
travailleurs et ces familles mais pour
toute la provence parce qu'on est
capable de contrer les contrôles et la
pandémie cas vaccination commencera dès
la semaine prochaine dans les
installations des fermes may bowles a
pill les entreprises
amazon m'bolhi foot de la région aussi
commenceront bientôt avec signer leurs
employés m
ce programme pilote doit permettre de
vacciner des milliers de travailleurs au
cours des prochaines semaines avec
l'espoir d'être ensuite étendu à
d'autres lieux de travail de la province
ici qu amy faye raizen radio canada
toronto